they reject nation Greg Alba here I'm
John we're gonna watch our weird trailer
aldo Jones sent it to us himself want us
to react to it Avengers infinity or
super bowl weird trailer oh boy I
remember that Super Bowl trailer but
Aldo we need a winter trailer for the
latest one get to it what's taking you
so long to do all this crazy edit one
man give me my free content all right
let's do it and patron of the day shout
out for Derek Mitchell
[Music]
[Applause]
I wrote I did pretty well how's mom's
spaghetti
it is Wednesday in my jeans
[Music]
ready no no
[Music]
[Music]
he's gonna haul
she held his art
[Music]
this is gonna be awesome
do Aldo
where was Batman's newspaper for the
longer videos he'll do that nice
Kaiser Marrero thank you so much for
supporting Aldo Jones you get a shout
out here too buddy
I was born at Kaiser Permanente really
Lorenzo Pastorini guys clearly in
italiano so I like him
[Music]
damn how do people find this they must
put this on like a giant monitor Wow
yeah Nicholas Thomas that's a great
weird headshot right there hey all you
guys are wonderful people and most of
you are ethnic so I love that nibbly
love that man that was some funny-ass
[ __ ] dude how those editing is amazing
on this one this was the most like wild
like I'm used to him like tweaking
images and throwing things in the
background but this would he like really
cut up with my other movie I mean the
Super Bowl trailers are short so he like
expanded extended a lot especially all
the inserts of like when he goes this is
a - they're kind to all the people
saying this is my favorite Michael Scott
is actually one of my favorite moments
of the office have you seen that episode
the moment when Toby comes back actually
you know what as much as I love is crazy
weird editing my favorite part is when
iron man holds up the sign yeah this is
fun Ernie hidden gems in here thank God
I feel the pressure to have to look for
some of these hidden gems I mean I found
the shield I don't know where the hope
in the back ground - it was cool at the
- Sherlock Holmes for like three years
now Andrew Gordon from the movie source
announcement like I just want one joke
about them both being Sherlock Holmes
I'm like yo Andrew you told me this joke
like 15 times yeah don't worry
although Jones got how the jokes got you
back though hey patron the day shout-out
for Derek Mitchell Derek Mitchell I just
started getting to know you my friend
this guy's from Kansas City the place
where all the magic happens where
everyone wants to travel - is Kansas
City I know so much that goes on in
Kansas City it is not a land of nowhere
what he told me is he wants to be a
professional nerd he has a passion for
working with computers that sort of
shouting you I hear because clearly Aldo
Jones he works with computers all
frickin day long my friend and maybe
instead of being some high-tech computer
dude you can just make weird trailers
instead I think that's more of where
your passions at and I asked him the
other day you know like what are his
like favorite movies in the past year
and a half I'm
read the whole thing for us first and
foremost I'm a big Marvel movies British
that's we're all people from Britain go
in America as Kansas City I'm a big
Marvel movie fan so pretty much anything
from the MCU overall haven't really been
that impressed with DC II you say Wonder
Woman and I'm one of the weirdos
actually enjoyed Suicide Squad outside
of that pretty much any action sci fi i
never really got much into anime and try
to keep up with Marvel TV shows but it's
hard to keep up with the defenders all
their own series and agents of shield
it's weird but actually think DC does
better on TV or more others better with
movies sorry with the long response
Derrick fair all I want to say is that
was a long response and in what the heck
what the hell is your problem yeah I
don't care for these long-ass responses
you don't know me unless you're a girl
on patreon could do without it okay keep
it like five words or blows what do you
think we're intimate with each other
what you think we got some trust
connection alright alright you ate some
chick you would dude oh great dudes keep
it brief so no more long responses but
I'm serious now my friend don't give
long response so man you could talk as
long as you want yeah message plenty of
people on patreon we have long-ass
messages back and forth as a whole bunch
of people so don't feel shy to share as
much as you want I know right now you're
doing lyft and uber as your main source
of income but don't worry my friend you
do seem like a really passionate dude
and that passion will take you very far
in life and maybe get you out of that
slump which is Kansas City pup pup pup
passion subscribe at the real rejects
click that notification though we'll
catch you soon